what's up everyone hey welcome back to
witty we are doing simulation interviews
here and we are talking to John Bates
now what's up how you doing thanks I had
to be a show and you're welcome thank
you very much
and you are the founder of executive
speaking success twelve and a half years
now you know yes I've been I've been
doing this for maybe even a lot longer
than that but it was for fun and beer
money and when I really started this
company like when I got the LLC filed
and went whole hog on it was about six
years ago so you know kind of depends on
what what we're talking about in terms
of like how long I've been doing this as
a company six years you know twelve
years as committed ly maybe even a
little bit more and so it's been a fun
ride and it was great getting to know
you for the brief period that we did
just earlier and even just now you sat
down maybe we should start with what we
just mentioned when we sat down which is
how cool is it to be around so many
powerful women it's really cool and you
know like like I just mentioned I think
that witty is a really good example if
you have any question about whether we
still undervalue women just come to this
conference so and look at the just
powerhouse women that are walking around
and and here we are you know this this
if if if these were all men this
conference would cost way more be way
harder to get into you know so it's one
of the reasons I'm you know excited to
be here it's just such an amazing event
you know I love all of the conversations
with women that are thinking about
society in a way that it's like how do
we maximize the potential of women to be
in a place of power and I'm like hell
yeah let's get there yeah you know if
you look at the at the science around
just about anything I mean pretty much
anything
when women are doing better mmm
everything's doing better yeah you know
and you go look and in a place where
women are be more happy life that's even
a marriage right and I mean if you go
look at it where women are doing better
the environments doing better where
women are doing better animals are doing
better where women are doing better you
know fairness is doing better where
women are doing better men are doing
better you know I mean they're just it's
yeah I'm really excited and happy to be
able to be here and potentially offer
something that can forward that action
you know cuz I definitely think we need
women in places of power we need women's
voices I think everybody's got something
to offer and I think women have
something particularly useful and
critical especially for us where we are
today yeah yeah there's been a lot of
let's stay on this topic for a bit sure
and then we'll get to more about what
you built so today it seems as though we
live in the rocket era and the cellphone
era and the computers and the
biotechnology and all these things that
are very like logical and and and then
we're kind of putting to the side the
the sociology the psychology the feeling
the emotion heart yeah and like men
aren't very vulnerable especially not in
public and on television well yeah no
you're I trained not to do that right
yeah yeah you know I made a conscious
effort years ago to stop being that way
yeah and I made a conscious scary
difficult to follow through on all the
time promise to myself that I would
share my feelings that I would let my
feelings up I would experience my
feelings and not try to hide them from
the people around me and it's you know
it's still sometimes hard to do that and
the the difference that it makes is
pretty pretty palpable I mean people
like you know stuff happens that
wouldn't happen if I wasn't willing to
take the risk that that feels like to do
that and I think whenever anyone does
that it opens it up for everyone to do
that no it's one of those things you
know and and leadership is only things I
think about a lot and it's one of the
things that you see monkey do a little
bit very much very much like that and
you know I and here's the critical
component about it for leadership I
think is it's easy to be a leader at the
buffet table mm-hmm I follow me I'll go
first you know okay leader this analogy
I know it's here it you know so that's
great and that's leadership but that
doesn't that's not when leadership makes
a difference like being a leader to the
buffet table not really making a
difference but being a leader at on the
dance floor when nobody is dancing
that's right you're absolutely right
being a leader when it comes to being
vulnerable showing your emotion
expressing your emotion you know and
something else I think is really
important along those lines is the the
most important lessons that we have to
share are the lessons we learned in the
hardest most embarrassing worst most
horrible times of our lives but nobody
ever wants to talk about that no one
wants to go first in that conversation
but if somebody goes first everybody
wants to go second or third or fourth or
we'll shut the bar down with that you
know so you could go first at the buffet
table but that doesn't make a difference
but if you want to be a leader that
makes a difference you could go first in
that conversation and free up the space
open up the space for other people to
share their stories and what they
learned out of those horrible moments
that's useful you know gosh I love this
analogy Oh Alfredo we gotta write this
one down and keep it yeah it makes a
ladder yeah the buffet versus being a
leader on an empty dance floor yeah
exactly not you're good like and it's
you know it's when no one else wants to
go first but it's worthwhile yeah for
someone to do it that's when being a
leader makes a difference
you go first and you open it up for
everybody and all of a sudden the
dancefloor is crowded nobody even
remembers you went first yeah but you do
yeah you know you did yo you know and
now everybody's dancing Rose dances so
so okay so now we have a sometimes
culture does things to us especially to
kids and to women and minorities that
kind of pushes them at the states where
it's more difficult for them to step
forward and sure yeah alfiri oh
absolutely yeah this is this is this is
powerful this is why I love being here
cuz it's like it's very counterculture
to be here right now it's the kind of at
the edge of what's going on in the world
in that sense
okay so let's unpack John what's
unpacked you okay so when we were
talking earlier about this I really felt
goose bumps when you said that when you
were talking about your experience with
your first company yeah yeah and the
first venture funded 80 million bucks
venture funded and dot-com yeah and then
you went through tell us what you went
through in like in like how that made
who you are today yeah okay so I you
know I had been I've been on the
internet since 1987 had an email address
started working at UCLA on the first
ever Macintosh computer lab connected to
the Internet anywhere in the world and
then in 1994 I went to a place called
virtual Vegas and I was a state employee
there and then did a number of other
things and then in 1997-98 we there were
there were a couple of the guys that
came to me and we started this thing
called big words calm and we sold text
books over the Internet cheaper than the
bookstore delivered to your door you
know and I'm telling you this was in the
day when you could not go buy widgets
and parts for your website you had to
hand code everything and it was all from
the ground up and nobody was ready for
shipping books quickly and I mean you
know it was a it was a an amazing
experience and we did a lot of things
right we were
one of those people one of those
companies that spent it all on a you
know Super Bowl ad and then couldn't
fulfill our orders or something but at
the end of the day we were not our
investors said we were not going to be
profitable fast enough and you know we
we had the the thought at the time and
it's still there's still some truth to
this I think but the fun at the time was
you've got a growth market share as long
as you're growing and growing market
share we can find more funding for you
you know so man we just went at it we
were not as worried about being
profitable because that wasn't the game
yet you know we knew that would come but
that wasn't game yet and then the market
turned and all of a sudden they couldn't
get money for us anymore
and everything you know just dried up
and we had missed our possible
opportunity to sell to Amazon cuz no we
wanted to go public ourselves you know
it wouldn't make that mistake again and
and so in October on October 20th of
2000 our investors after putting 80
million dollars into this company came
and said you know what we're pulling the
plug you're not going to be profitable
fast enough we had done a ton of things
right but we were not gonna be
profitable fast enough and out we went
on our butts you know went across the
street from South Park in San Francisco
to the 21st amendment and got drunk and
cried you know Wow and then I you know I
had gone into this and what I didn't
realize until a little bit later was I
had this context of I want to succeed me
yeah right and of course I want to take
everybody with me yeah but it's about me
and I want to succeed and I also I was
approaching everything like opportunity
only knocks once this is my you know I'm
putting my soul on the line this is
gonna happen we're you know so that that
was motivating in a lot of ways but it
but what do you do when your context is
opportunity only knocks once and they
just pulled the plug on your company you
know well I didn't know what to do so I
I was just I was angry I was ashamed
I was embarrassed I was scared I was
hurt and I just every unpleasant emotion
that name and super freaking anxious
because it did kind of seem like the
whole world was just imploding when you
live I was living in San Francisco at
the time and so was the dot-com Center
and everything was just going and so it
was a really tough time in a few months
after that I had about with this thing
called stevens-johnson syndrome which is
starts out with little ulcerations in
your mucous membrane and I mean all your
mucous membrane like my eyelids
everything it was like ulcers and
weeping ulcers and then dots on your
skin and then the endgame is the dots
connect your skin Salaf soft you go
blind and die in the burn unit not a
pretty thing and it can be caused by a
lot of things I mean it's a syndrome so
they don't really know it means we don't
know you know syndrome equals we don't
know so it seems like mine is
particularly triggered by lack of sleep
and stress so what was I doing I you
know I had just spent several years not
sleeping at all and practically and now
I was super ultra stressed on top of it
and so I just had this and all of a
sudden I ended up in the emergency room
and I'm sitting on this bed and doctors
are coming from all over the Bay Area to
see me because this is such a rare thing
they want to like you know they're
looking at our mouths and looking at the
dots on my skin and they the scary thing
was they were the doctors that were in
charge of taking care of me were looking
at me like they didn't know if I was
going to make it like you can see it you
know their eyes and I was like damn you
know like I and so I sat there and
really fir you know I was in the
hospital for probably 18 or 24 hours
more than whatever you know awake and
freaked out the whole time and and I
spent that whole time kind of thinking
am I gonna make it or not
so I was really confronting that I might
not make it
and my life just looked really small to
me I you know looked back over my life
and what I've done and if this was it
would I be okay with that and I was not
okay with that because it was selfish it
was small and and I just thought wow
what a petty life you just lived you
know and so I promised myself that if I
got out of that hotel room or that hotel
room we're sitting in return I got out
of that hospital room and I was alive I
was gonna do things differently and I
decided like all I want is to make a
difference I just want to know that
whatever I did made a difference if I'm
the CEO from the bottle washer if I'm
carrying water from chopping wood I
don't care I want to do what I'm doing
well and I want to make a difference and
I got to walk out of the hospital and I
was not okay for a long time and I was
so happy to be alive you know and I and
I really started approaching everything
differently and the bottom line for me
was I just wanted to make a difference
and I and and I wanted to be able to
look back on my life and go okay I I
gave it my all as opposed to I made it
all about me so first of all the
cultures pressure on huge huge this is
the little sleep that the doors only
open for a moment you gotta seize the
opportunity the constant push for like
success and fame and money and all that
stuff and then the and then the just
this the story of how one can just go up
up up up up and then and then down to a
point of like doctors coming from around
the bay to see something it's so rare
and then just the the realization
being that no matter what I do with my
life and my time I need to make a
difference I want to be part of the
tribe that's recognized I want to
recognize others I want to be recognized
yeah I mean for me you know I just I
mean and for me I it was a very internal
thing and I think in a in you know in
kind of a good way I just wanted to know
I had done my best to make a difference
and if I get recognized great and if I
don't get recognized I don't care I pick
up trash when people aren't watching and
I made a commitment a long time ago to
leave every bathroom I go into a little
bit better here then you know when I
walk rate would you know one of my
favorite ways to do that is to just push
the paper towels down I do that I'll
step on there and stop them to the
bottom right and and you know so I've
spent 15 years and I can honestly tell
you that except for a few times when the
bathroom was already so pristine there
was just nothing I could figure out to
do which is not that often it was very
very very rare here every bathroom I've
gone into is ended up a little bit
better somehow or another and and I and
that's a really good model yeah you know
that little difference almost yeah
everywhere you go I mean and I love the
bathroom to rights just yeah is equal in
like just simplicity yeah just walking
by so I'm just giving them a smile right
yeah well yeah totally just you know
just them as well they smiled back yeah
it's so much different yeah yeah and so
you know that I mean I know the funny
thing is because probably there's some
people listening who have businesses and
care about that too and I certainly do I
mean I love what Ron Finley said in his
TED talk he is the gangster gardener and
he said the funny thing about
sustainability is you have to sustain it
which you know you got to make money or
your business doesn't just isn't
sustainable
yeah Tara was just on the show and she
said a passion to profit yeah I and I
look I'm all for that
you know the lay
holy topic on some level but it's kind
of some stuff you teach as well well
yeah yeah and one of the things that I
that I realized fairly recently as I
look back over my life and there was a
period of my life the majority of my
adult life I was an entrepreneur trying
to make money I mean of course I wanted
to be nice to people and help and things
like that but like you know I was
interested in making money that's what
you do as an entrepreneur you find an
idea that's gonna make money we'll just
make money and after that experience and
a little bit more soul-searching and
some other you know like stuff I finally
when I went into this full-time six
years ago and started this company as a
full-time gig and there stopped doing
anything else scary scary scary yeah I
had always been 50 grand in debt and had
millions of dollars worth of useless
stock when I started this company in the
face of everyone telling me you don't
want to do that like you're not gonna
make any money at that there's no money
in that like that's they're a dime a
dozen don't do that so I I cried about
it for a while and then I went wait a
minute like I get I I have looked at my
life I think this is what I have to
offer of value I'm gonna do it anyway
because I've been doing it like I said
for fun and grier money and I saw the
difference that it made so I said this
is I can make a difference here so
forget if I make money who cares I'm
just gonna do this and see what happens
first year and a half I went even
further in debt SEC and a year to
started turn around third year I made
more than I've ever made in my whole
life
fourth year doubled that plus 50 or
tripled that plus sixth year kind of
broke even this year you know I say that
I'm gonna blow that all out of the water
and the funny thing is when I was
focused on money I had debt now when I
switched the focus to providing value
even in the face of not being sure it
would make money but for sure it
provided value all of a sudden I'm
making money owned by the way like six
years that's not all of a sudden you
know right I like to tell people
while doing what you love is important
because it's easy to be an overnight
success if you do something for 10 years
we were just talking about it just an
hour ago when we were walking is that
everybody wants to succeed but people
want overnight success and that doesn't
happen in just six years of time and and
like you said you shifted your mentality
to providing value yes we were also
talking about that earlier today that
when you have a conversation with
someone shift the focus to know what you
can get but what you can give yeah and
when you do that you will be shocked at
what happens
yeah but want to start talking to you
people want to start doing business with
you people want to befriend ya they know
that what you're doing is you're helping
them first yeah and then they see that
and they're like I want to help you too
yeah yeah it's one of the things I talk
about in my trainings cuz I like to I
like to show people the neurobiological
underpinnings of communication I say
communicating with human beings is not
logical it's biological and when you
understand the biology you can make it
logical again but people go in thinking
logics gonna win by itself are always
disappointed and never as effective as
they could be ah that's so good that
that just resonates so here's a funny
one I'm very proud of this logic is
necessary but it's not sufficient yeah
yeah you know you got to have that logic
but if that's all you have somebody else
with logic and an emotional connection
is gonna totally leave you be you know
truth and you know so gotta have both
polymath the wide range of knowledge
logic and execution but also the wide
range of emotional intelligence yeah you
tap into any of those sales any of these
skills and switch between them add them
together that's just you're gonna turn
yeah and I always ask people who would
be more successful you exactly as you
are right now with all the skills you've
got and a poor communicator or you
exactly as you are right now with all
the skills you've got and a great
communicator yeah
you know would you say them the bulk of
what you're doing is teaching people how
to become exceptional communicators I
would say so yeah well you know here's
my why my why is to bring out what's
awesome inside every person so it can
live in the world and make a real
difference and I do that by doing you
know one-on-one coaching I do large
group trainings I do small group
trainings and it's all based in human
evolutionary biology and I call it
leadership communication because I think
leadership is a function of
communication and once people understand
the fundamental biology that underpins
human communication it's all of a sudden
it frees people up they get the
principles and then they can apply them
to their own style and be far more
effective in all forms of communication
I get brought in a lot to work on people
because they want to have the this
year's customer summit they want all
their top executives to give ted-like
talks so I go in and work with them on
that but that's just the tip of the
iceberg I mean that's the end result but
to get to that there's all these things
that we work on and then I train people
in that also make them yes very good on
stage communicators but also really good
communicators one-on-one and in small
small groups and large groups and
understanding what it is in your
communication that's actually going to
move people to take action and to
remember you and to feel loyal to you
and to trust you and care about you it's
what everybody wants but people never
never do we get shown how to do that
you know everybody still thinks it's a
PowerPoint with a whole bunch of bullet
points that you kind of talk over and
don't read the bullet points and that's
about as much training as anybody ever
gets it's a lot of experience you
learning a lot of falling on your face
yeah over and over again and then all of
a sudden you like you said there's this
difference
in some of my friends and we call it n
just the number of people that are in
the group at a time yeah so if it's just
n2 is just two people talking to each
other yeah then your interpersonal
skills have you've almost a different
tool kit you have a you-you'd accessing
different tools on yeah okay yeah then
when you're in a group of four maybe
you're a six
yeah and a lot of really good thing to
do is you know how to be a good question
asker that's a really you're absolutely
right yes people that you care by asking
them good questions yeah and then
actively listening different ways give
those two ears over yeah there's two
goods right yeah and then paraphrase
what they said yeah show them that you
listen yeah and then ask them another
good question
and then eventually they'll be like hey
my turn ask you questions yeah yeah yeah
yeah no you're absolutely right and you
know that that that listening part is
super important but one of the things
that I like to point out to people when
I'm doing my large group training let's
say I'll have a slide where I talk about
this and I'll say okay so what's going
on more in this room right now there's
like you know 400 people in me and I say
what's going on more in here talking or
listening people think about it for a
second they're like oh listening I'm
like yeah that's right way more
listening than talking right now and I
think this has actually been miss name
because people call what I'm doing right
now I talk it's not a talk
it's a listener that's a good point I've
done this a lot when people aren't
listening and it's just not as good so
really the power is not in me talking
the power is in you listening and I
honor that as a speaker I acknowledge
that if I don't get that I will never be
as effective or as good as I could be
and I think it's really really important
to remember the power is not in the
talking the power is in the listening
and there's this kind of I wonder the
logical minds trying to put percentages
on it but like as any as an example it's
that's like an abstract example it's
it's also both in this listener to be
really good at listening as it is in the
storyteller the person that is doing the
talking to him it get fun in it - in
relay battle yep
yeah both the same time yeah but you
know that there's a thing that I
selfishly because you know I could name
it I named it the baits equation and if
you're about it it goes like this one
times 20 times 3,000 okay that's me
speaking for 20 minutes 3,000 people
okay that's 60,000 minutes of human life
ah that I use up in one 20-minute talk
to 3,000 people that's divided by by
60,000 hours I'm only talking for 20
minutes but with 3,000 people in the
audience I just burned a thousand hours
of human life so I better practice
I better be willing to put in the time
it's gonna take to make that worth their
while hey high five for that yeah all
right okay that's a really good one
because times the most valuable come on
it's the only thing ya really think yeah
thirty thousand days yeah yeah it yeah
and then with the things you said
there's you're giving 20 minutes but
you're taking a thousand hours of human
life that's right that's right that's so
pretty good on it that way yeah so now
here's what that makes possible
practicing right like you could actually
practice if you thought of it that way
the other way I like to do it is add up
everybody's salary in the room I'm doing
a day-long training for a big company
and they've flown in all their top
executives what would those guys charge
me for a day of their time all their
flights all their hotels all their meals
right paying me flying me and putting me
up like I don't think I could afford
that but somebody's paying for that and
if I'm not worth that then I'm not gonna
get invited back very much you know so
lots of ways to run that but though you
could
with monetary value on yeah like if I
was if you yes yeah if everyone's
getting paid about 30 bucks an hour yeah
30 that I was in dollars yeah and now
let's knock it up to some top executives
at global companies they're making more
like 300 bucks an hour or more $100,000
of right it's 120 minute talk yeah yeah
it's interesting I really like that
because I think it also puts into
perspective the it's like a it's like
time entering into reality in a
different way than normal yeah that's
what you're doing and I'm with and we we
do that to you currently in the process
of authoring a book talking about the
importance of time and the importance of
love when you're you're you're so young
and you're able to cram in this this
world around you yeah there are certain
things that you can cram in and then
take in that are of a higher value yes
and it's it's difficult to portion a
line it's ten minutes but this 10
minutes is gonna pay back much better
than that 10 minutes right yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah listen I mean you know it's
one of those things some point along the
road you see that and the sooner you see
it the more valuable and worthwhile
everything you end up doing after that
is right man really I'm so happy we got
here yeah cool yeah so so are you so
debates equations happening like you're
teaching of that yeah yeah cuz there's a
lot of a lot cuz you know look I mean I
you know these folks are busy like they
are super super busy yeah and it's hard
for them I think how hard it is for me
right and I'm not a fortune 50 fortune
20 top 20 executive it's hard for me to
put time in my calendar to practice the
talk because I can't just wing it you
know I'm pretty good at that but it's
never gonna be as good as it could be if
I do it that way so how do I justify the
time it's going to take me to practice
to get this as good as it could be
oh let's
to run the Bates equation right because
if I'm just giving a 20-minute talk well
that doesn't seem like much to prep for
but if I'm burning up $300,000 of the
company's money with that 20 minute talk
to 3000 employees that all make 300
bucks or whatever an hour well now I
could justify some prep time for that so
that's one of the biggest things for me
of the Bates equation and you know it
makes me think of Steve Jobs I have a
friend who worked with him on all those
talks after they created the talk after
it was all like finalized what he was
going to say he committed to one hour of
practice for every minute that he was
going to be onstage
yeah 45-minute talk 45 hours of practice
and you know people get out of doing
that by saying oh he's a natural well
guess what you could be pretty much
natural too if you practice that much
are you kidding me you know it's how we
get out of practice oh he's a natural no
you just don't a practice I don't want
to practice yeah okay so I kind of want
to I want to come back to to what we
were discussing just a little bit yeah
and your thoughts about to hear your
thoughts about this we talked a lot
about maximizing human potential yeah
maximizing the potential children in
this world there's a lot of exponential
technology that's going on a lot of
automation yeah that's happening
robotics so the question that we would
like to ask you is then how do we how do
we figure out what is good for the kids
to invest their time in to learn so good
question yeah I have a two-year-old son
you know I'm like what what do I do
yeah what do I encourage him in you know
what's his life gonna be louder you
teach robot proof skills yeah exactly
exactly yeah I mean and can I just jump
even further than that for a second how
and this might be a question that would
be worth answering
anyway but if you project it out far
enough and it might not even be all that
far
all of a sudden artificial intelligence
and robotics and all that stuff is doing
everything pretty much there's a few
positions left but most people do not
have to work but we get all of our value
and all of our self-worth and all just
our entire picture of ourselves through
the work we do or that we don't work and
we're unemployed and what we know like
but how do we get give people something
fulfilling and challenging that's not
work when they don't have to work
anymore like how are we going to work
this you know and and if everybody's got
universal basic income
how do people how do we make people how
do we make people's lives fulfilling and
how do we get them to value that
universal basic income and have a
fulfilling life versus just sitting
around and you know undervaluing the
money that that they get and that the
stuff they're doing you know that could
be a really if we can answer that
question for that distant future there
might be some things we could do in our
current present that would also
alleviate a lot of this frustration and
suffering that we see around us so I
will we'll get to some more
communications stuff he is get there
what are your thoughts about wealth
inequality posing an existential risk to
a significant portion of society so
especially low socioeconomic status in
the middle yeah well you know I just
noticed that any time in history that I
know of where enough people felt like
they didn't have any of the pie they
ruined the pie mm-hmm right so I just
think that if if really really
ridiculously upper wealth type people
are actually
thinking at all and they're being
selfish
they would not hoard stuff they would
put the wealth back out so it can
circulate so the people at the bottom
felt like they had some piece of the pie
because I'll tell you what you got a
teeny tiny slice of pie you're gonna
work to grow that pie mmm you have no
slice mm-hmm you just wanted to destroy
the pie mm-hmm that's what I think then
sometimes there are very advanced
artificial intelligent robots with guns
that are protecting the pie and then
you're like now well yeah yeah and then
it's like now would you get finally got
to a point where it's not about a
thousand person army protecting the
castle
yeah that's not fleets of drones and
necks that are I mean and that's and you
know when you're right and there's a
dystopian future awaiting us if we go
down that path I just wonder what about
a fulfilling life you know it took me
too long to start asking myself what's
fulfilling versus what's gonna make
money but when I did my life got way
more fulfilling and I made more money
and I look at the people that are
willing to trash the environment for a
profit
and I wonder what world do they want to
live in and they want their kids to live
in if the environment is thrashed and
you're a billionaire is that worth it I
don't think it would be for me
you know and and so I think that we are
asking ourselves a lot of the wrong
questions and that has us chasing after
a lot of the of just not as fulfilling
solutions I think a woman's perspective
will actually help us oh get totally get
so the better
questions and yatter well that may be
even a better distribution of the pie
yeah and growing the pie in a more
effective way I think it might oh I'm
pretty sure well yeah but it will yeah
I'm pretty sure I mean and you know you
could go as far as our biology you don't
have to go very far
yeah yeah that like that was a good one
it's not logical it's biologically yeah
well and you know men are egress men are
alike exponential like sperm thousands
of them
you know women don't have that luxury
their K growth mammal growth and I we're
like bacteria when it comes to that and
they're like mammals you know K growth
invest big in one thing there's a finite
number of eggs that they're ever going
to have available and when they get
pregnant they it's a nine-month
commitment just to get that thing into
the world you know so I just think that
the the biology supports their point of
view being more long-term and more
sustainable you know and we both have a
part to play but I think we've been
missing their part too much and we could
use a lot more of that yeah yeah and the
communications side of between men and
women between politicians between
parents and kids between kids and kids
and the teachers and the community all
these different aspects of communication
so with your specific focus is it more
so on the executive side of things is it
and how does it go ahead and expand upon
that for us
so um you know I think that I'm sneaking
in under the radar to just have a human
perspective but it does I do get brought
in a lot for executive presence better
speaking skills better connection skills
you know that kind of stuff
and all of that stuff humanity on the
side yeah yeah well all that stuff is
super important in business and it just
also happens to be super important in
life and one of the things that I
definitely believe is that there's just
no way that people can be as effective
as they want to be at work if they don't
have their life handled - and whatever
it is they're doing that doesn't work
I'm a big fan of the saying how you do
anything is how you do everything so if
something's not working it's not just
not working at home it's not working
everywhere and if something's not
working at work well it's not working at
home either you know so there's this and
you know what one of the reasons people
told me when I wanted to start this that
it was never you know make me any money
is because they're like speaker coach
are you kidding speaker coach so I mean
I don't even call myself a speaker coach
anymore because it just draws up too
many bad images for people but the thing
is it never for me was about things like
well this is a closed position and this
is an open position so you should go
like this
and open up you know I'm like stand like
this don't stand like that that's not
what I do what I realized early on was
that all those experiences people have
had throughout their lives those are the
things that are driving their issues
with communication so one example got
brought in to work with this guy who was
really great guy doing a great job but
just not such a great presenter when it
came time to present to the board and
stuff so I went in I worked with him on
the content I loved getting in early and
doing that stuff and then once we had it
so he was saying what he wanted to say
he started delivering it for me and I
had him picture the board attorney and
all of a sudden he got all tense and
awkward and weird and whatever I was
like okay what's going on for you here
now I noticed that everything was cool
till we said go and then all of a sudden
something changed what does this remind
you of what's coming up for you he goes
oh my gosh
it's like when I was a little kid and I
was at a new school again because my dad
had a job that we had to move every
couple of years so almost every year I
was the new kid at school again and when
I get in front of the board that's what
comes up for me I feel like I'm the new
kid and are they gonna like me and will
it you know and either dude from you
know early high school maybe even junior
high or earlier still wired up they're
still wired up there right and the
minute that he got that and we saw that
and we uncovered it bingo gone yeah just
needed unconscious neither uncover it
the minute you see those things they
don't have you anymore you now have them
right and so that that's the you know
that kind of work is the focus I want to
go after the deep root issues I want to
go after the key principles to remember
and use I don't want to do surface
bandages and patch jobs I want to like
work it from the from the depths so that
it is done you know that's a really good
example those types of examples are the
ones I think that really resonate with
people there's a lot of what goes on is
patterns from our childhood yep yep and
we trauma from our childhood absolutely
and we don't sometimes like you said but
just it's hidden from sight until it's
really uncovered in it a lot of it
requires a space and vulnerability and
you know active listening for other
people and and just you know coaching at
the right moments and then a person
being willing to take it that's right
and being like whoa yeah yeah like
that's and then and then going forth and
being confident yes and going through it
and being like I actually can do this
yeah thing that's a really good example
there's so many examples like that from
from childhood because by the time we
become older I you know once we get
especially towards the end of our lives
we only remember things
like one thing per year yeah African
thing per there so I mean it's just how
do you how to even remember what
happened in your childhood
yeah and in your family your community
to earth your friends that led you to
who you became yeah that's a lot yeah oh
it is and it's you know and there's just
such an accretion of decisions we make
about ourselves and then forget we made
mm-hmm you know like one of the things
that was just driving my life is this
time when I was a little kid and I was
looking through time and Newsweek and
stuff and there was a big famine in
Ethiopia and I was about 11 or 12 at the
time
oh my god I mean I I was in just this
Greek depression for months and I think
the decision I made was something like
the world is screwed and it's just
getting worse and there's just nothing I
can do about cuz it just seems so much
bigger than me that you know and and so
yeah huge and overwhelming okay and then
I forgot then I forgot I did that but
Here I am at 38 40 living like a 19 year
old rock star you know not enough no
investment in the future at all it's all
about like pleasure in the moment that's
not who I wanted to be but that decision
of an eleven year old that the world is
screwed up and it's just getting worse
if I really thought that that's exactly
how I would act I would have a great
time tonight who cares what's on the
credit card
you know forget any long-term investment
because the world is just going down but
that's not what I really thought that's
not who I that grown up John Bates
wanted to be coming from but I had to
identify that I had made that choice so
long ago so that I could then just go
okay I get it and I don't actually
believe that I want to have you know I'm
ready to make long-term investments and
I want to come from this like we could
make a difference in this place and
we're going to make it
better and you know so now I have a wife
and a child and you know that's a
heavy-duty investment in the future
especially for a guy who was just that
was allergic you know I was allergic to
that you know but uncovering that stuff
you know and that stuff's all over and
it it has a huge impact on people's
leadership has a huge impact on people's
communication has a huge impact on their
relationships their life you know seem
to be coming back a lot communication
also to your example molding a child's
mind into this complex job now yeah now
you've taken that on oh man and that's a
whole new field of Education for an
adult yeah yeah they don't come with an
instruction thank goodness okay so I
just like I would love to hear maybe
another example of a time that you had a
client that you were working with that
was like an aha moment from like like
the like the example about about public
speaking oh yes the same thing for the
for going into school everything yeah
yours that yeah can I give you a this is
one that's similar along those lines but
this is one of the big big insights that
I've had recently sweet but in doing
this work for a long time and I just
recently had a what I what for me was a
very valuable really big insight I was
working with a client that you know it's
a big fortune top ten company and I'm
not supposed to say their name but you
know they're a gigantic manufacturing
company that makes very difficult stuff
to make yet we all you know all of us
who travel use their stuff a lot and and
so they came to me and they said John we
want to do this big summit we haven't
done one for a while we're gonna bring
in all of our top customers we want them
to talk to us we want to know what they
want we want to have a dialogue and we
want all of our top executives in the
company everybody who runs a division is
going to give a ten
two 12-minute talk and we want to be
like Ted you know Ted like talk and and
so I said okay well here's what we got
to do and they went with my program so
what that meant is all I mean and you
know one thing I love about the work I
do is I get it work with people like
that
and they have been picked and chosen and
worked their way up so by the time I get
to work with somebody who's a top
executive at a company like this they're
really smart like it's not like a bunch
of jerks or dum-dums get through all the
way so that's pretty cool and and they
were all because of this manufacturing
very scientific stuff they were all very
um they were all very logical you know
and so first of all one of the you know
the ice because they went with the
program the way I said we should do it
and I think it was important they did
this they all worked with me for almost
six months five and a half months we
worked on their talk and it wasn't their
communications team without them they
worked on the talk with me and their
communications team helped them yeah it
was no they just threw it over the wall
to their communications team that never
works by the way so they all worked with
me that's a lot of time and effort on
their part six months ahead of time six
months ahead of time we met every month
talked in between a couple of times they
had a lot of work to do and that was for
a 10 to 12 minute talk right so they put
in the effort so huge kudos to them and
then I you know I noticed that in
settings like that people always want to
establish their credibility joining me
to establish my credibility and I'm new
in this position and you know I want to
establish my credibility well I read a
study a long time ago that said if
you've got letters after your name like
PhD or CPA or whatever your credibility
is already assumed and I got to believe
that if you have a card with this
company's name on it that says you're a
VP come on like your credibility is
assumed you're on stage for heaven's
sake we're not going to build your
credibility that would actually tarnish
your credibility continue building it
yeah it was it's almost as though you
build you you validate that credibility
by saying very interesting things yeah
yeah yeah I've been hurt yeah you don't
have to get up there and tell him about
all this stuff
right like trot out the degrees or
whatever lame so so it was a little bit
of struggle and an arm wrestle some of
them but I got everybody to do what I
call their some version of their
superhero origin story mm-hmm
where did you come from how did you end
up in this job what was the path and
what what do you care about that makes
it so you'd want to be here because you
could have been a lot of places but
you're here right every choice you may
let you hear why and so everybody in one
way or another started their talk and
whoa of that story through their talk
and versus getting up and establishing
their credibility and at the end of the
whole thing you know long story short
the woman I worked with said it was the
best event of her 25 plus year career at
this company doing these big events and
I was a big part of the reason that it
was so that's a huge compliment and I'm
stoked about that but it scared the
daylights out of me because I was like
okay how does this keep happening I have
to articulate what we did here I got to
get this clear for myself so I can say
it clearly what we did so I thought
about the whole event I thought about
what they told me you know the people
ran to the breakout sessions instead of
running away from the breakout sessions
to the coffee you know the people talk
to them they told them they were very
open they shared all kinds of stuff so
they just got everything they wanted out
of this event sorry and so they got
everything they wanted and I went really
well people were super open and
receptive and why did that happen and I
think a big reason for why that happened
after I played it all through my mind I
played you know all the speeches through
again and I thought about I thought
about and here's what dawned on me
instead of getting up and establishing
their credibility which would have just
tarnished their already existing
credibility anyway they got up and they
all shared a very carefully crafted
beautifully told little bit of story
about themselves they gave the audience
an insight into what made them tick in
who they were mm-hmm what makes them
tick yeah it's like it and we have a
shirt that says that by the way what
makes you tick yeah there you go
right it's a very interesting question
people want to know that and people were
like look I don't want to talk about
myself but I'm like this is not about
yourself you're telling us this story to
open something up for us it's actually
very generous of you to tell this story
it's not right so talking about your
values and morals and ethics and the
house of philosophies that then get us
to think in new ways and create it's a
really good creative process exactly so
I think what happened is rather than get
up and establish their credibility
person after person on this whole
executive team every single one of them
got up and established what I now call
their emotional credibility mm-hmm and I
actually trademarked that I have the
website it's gonna be the telephone next
book but cool that I believe is the key
to that kind of a thing is to get up
share something meaningful with you and
establish your emotional credibility
yeah and then everything else you say
will land for us in a very different
much more beneficial positive
influential persuasive way I remember
the story about musk almost running out
of money
I miss the forest forth rocket it was
the last attempt yeah and then he
succeeded and he was I almost remember
some sort of like very emotional yeah
whole durable state of that
communicating in that message yeah that
further locked people in that's right
and that's right yeah I think that's
absolutely right and people are like oh
I don't want to cry I don't want to
Masumi or emotional it's like okay well
then you're robbing them mm-hmm of some
of the most important stuff you could be
giving them mm-hmm you know that thought
is hard to get across to men that's for
sure oh no that's absolutely who I was
yes
guys yeah guess what guys I'm here to
tell you that being vulnerable and and
telling us building emotional
credibility yeah yeah that's well and
you know I have a friend who's a dear
friend a name Joshua mance and he just
wrote a book called the beauty of a
darker soul yeah and he was have you
heard of that is that we're familiar
with darker soul yeah there you go good
good good well so and he was in the
military and long story short a sniper
shot the guy that was right by him
killed that guy severed his femoral
artery and he flatlined for 15 minutes
he was dead for 15 minutes and they
didn't let him go and they brought him
back and he had no brain damage he was
okay I mean it's an absolute miracle and
he is now very very very involved with
you know rehabbing people from combat
arenas and PTSD and dealing with with
the moral injury of war versus just the
physical injuries and I think that his
work is very important and powerful not
just for veterans but like look Anthony
Bourdain just killed himself Kate Spade
just killed herself somebody's child in
junior high
has just killed themselves somebody's
high school kid just killed it right
there is an epidemic of this going on
and one of the key ways to get through
that is to talk about it and share it
and open up but nobody wants to do that
right nobody wants to open up and share
this stuff because they think people you
know oh I'll look weak or you know it'll
just give them another way that take you
know get at me or whatever but you know
we need to do that for each other we
need to open up and
vulnerable and share or else our lives
are not worthwhile and and you know this
the you know this generation has the
most incredible technology to connect
them that any generation has ever had
and yet they're the loneliest yeah that
what you just described is really
crucial to talk about you got probably
the most anxiety and the most depression
when it feels like it it feels like I
wasn't alive 50 years ago or 100 years
ago or a thousand years ago to know
these things but it really does feel
like a very anxious and depressed at
times yeah world especially with not
being able to socialize well yeah that's
people being so reclusive to our devices
but at the same time there is a little
bit of Darkness that that that that
shows up when people do choose to be
vulnerable to people that are not really
good at listening
sure I'm sure there and then and that's
what's really scary for people is well
I'm gonna open up and then nobody gives
a crap right that's kind of what the
thought is but finding people that are
willing to make space that are willing
to be confidential that are willing to
just be with your feelings and not coach
you yeah and then just work with you on
those feelings and just hear about them
and you know and then and then
eventually build enough report to where
it can be something that is trusted that
yeah I was trusted in that you can work
with your right that's major and look at
what we have right now like you said
there's a lot of worry about I was just
recently learning about Japan getting
access to technology before the United
States smartphone technology and
becoming more reclusive having more
social anxiety having less children
declining reality alright yeah all these
types of things that are just crazy and
then and then population is of course
increasing in other places of the world
where fertility rates are still like six
versus in developing nations that are
under
- and so replacement fertility rate for
a couple so we don't even know
population is is increasing or or
stabilizing after like nine billion we
don't even know even know what that is
it gonna decrease because people are
having less kids know etc so this is a
very strange human experiment that we
live in and it's really interesting that
you are talking about communication
emotional emotional Oh credible
credibility emotional credibility and I
mean those two things like emotional
credibility and communication I mean
this is a formula for people to be real
and raw and loving and caring and it
might it might just be like you know a
big part of the formula for figuring out
kind of what's going on across the world
with some of the exponential technology
conversation we were having earlier is
how do I like how do we work together
yes in this in the world and prevent a
socio-economic speciation and yeah yeah
so I'm really happy that we were able to
sit down I have a couple questions for
you from on the way out okay what's the
most beautiful thing in the world
it's my little boy land on my shield her
phone and sleep well I carry him around
you know and and and the gratitude I
feel for being safe and knowing that
we've got some you know we've got food
and shelter and water and and I can show
him what's beautiful in the world versus
like just trying to you know stay alive
or something and and just I haven't ever
felt a feeling like that ever you know
as he just lays on my shoulder and his
body starts to relax and his breathing
starts to get regular and he just falls
asleep right here
oh that's to me the most beautiful thing
so well articulated
Media made me feel like I was put in a
child sleep right yeah yeah yeah and
you're right in this world where we
already have access to music wa tea and
water and electricity yeah that way we
have the time to yeah contemplate our
existence yeah just be mean the need for
food and shelter and stuff yeah well you
know I like there's definitely a benefit
to hitting it later in life guys like if
I had to you know I ran away with my
rock band when I was 20 and if we would
have gotten really big and I would have
made all kinds of money I probably like
died early and you know bathtub or
something but you know this business is
the first time that I've really had any
kind of sustained ability to you know
really take care of myself and so I I
think I'm Way more grateful than I might
have been you know so that goes through
my mind too as I carry him around you
know yeah I love that thank you for
sharing it how about do you think we're
alone in the cosmos you know I could
really I mean I think there's a pretty
convincing argument for both you know it
on the one hand it seems ridiculous to
think that we're like how in the oh come
on like there's practically infinity
like how could there not be other life
and even if that is true given the
constraints of the physical universe as
we understand it there may be no way
we'll ever know right there we will
probably mean because if the speed of
light is the limit how we ever going to
hang out with other cultures you know
any mean other so that's within our own
galaxy yeah yeah I mean you know but
other galaxies yeah I mean even in our
own galaxy it's not easy
yeah right you know for four and a half
light-years yeah yeah way so and and
then you know I on the other hand I
think that I could buy the
the the supposition that it's just like
it's a one-off you know and and I
although I probably don't think that's
if at the end of if I did pick one I
probably would say well we're probably
not alone because that just seems a dumb
but I think we got to treat it like we
are because I don't think there's any
place we're going you know what I mean
like okay let's go to Mars but there's
no Van Allen belts protecting us from
the radiation there's no atmosphere that
you know right like it's not like we're
gonna just Oh
once we ruin this planet we can just go
to another planet right and and I'll
tell you what cheetahs they're very
special well and rhinos and mice and you
know anyone like those well because even
if there is life on another planet I
don't think there's cheetahs mmm-hmm I
don't think there's mice I think this is
Eagles or DTC's yeah like there's really
cool other stuff but not this you know
yeah yeah this is unique yeah you know
like like yeah there could be some
interesting things on like Enceladus
area rhobar yeah right all kinds of
stuff yeah yeah there seems there seems
to be cool stuff even in our solar
system boy but this diversity here is
yeah something so beautiful yeah I mean
and even if you found another exactly
earth-like planet with something sort of
like humans and something sort of like
every other animal we have it wouldn't
be this mm-hmm
you know this is unique this yeah yes
yeah absolutely I mean I I am NOT a
religious guy but I really like the
religious concept of stewardship yeah
stewardship
that's like come on okay God gave this
to you do you think he's gonna be
happier if you trash it or if you take
care of it yeah like come on yeah hello
you know yeah exactly
come on hello yeah yeah do you want the
kids for tomorrow too that inherit
something great yeah yeah
okay how about last question do you
think we're in a computer simulation
ooh definitely sometimes man and what is
it what did that feel like for you in
minutes sometimes
what if examples I'll tell you I when
this is so weird I don't think I've ever
told anybody this when I was a little
kid I used to have these dreams that
would almost make me sick to my stomach
it felt like there was a lot of pressure
in my not physical pressure in my brain
but like pressure in my mind and it felt
like the only way that I could figure
out to describe it to myself was it was
like something you know I didn't have
computers at this point like computers
weren't a big part of everything yet but
it felt like something with a much
higher bitrate was trying to download
stuff to me does that make sense right
and I just couldn't unlike a 14-4 and
and like 56 6 he's trying to talk to me
you know and it made me physically sick
to my stomach and my brain just felt
like it was gonna just just so pressured
and it was and and it felt like some
alien intelligence was trying to
communicate with me and I had these
dreams for a while you know and I don't
have him anymore and and I like I said I
don't think I've maybe told two other
people in my life
and so you know like maybe maybe we are
yeah and here's the bottom line it's
like the way that we definitely don't
know what happens outside of the third
dimension yet yeah so there you go this
is these feelings of whatever's going on
yeah that feel like whoa I can't I don't
know what it is but something's
happening and it's not right he it's not
yeah yeah well it's all getting
processed in here anyway so in a way
that's it's like what's out there yeah
it almost doesn't matter you know it's
like the whole experience is actually
getting processed right here
you know and here's why is the outside
impacting the look what's going on
whatever it whatever this it is in the
stereo it's outside of this third
dimension whatever the other what was
going on out soft stuff this rock and on
the other stars in an alley look what
what's so interesting about this
experiment orbiting this star yeah how
do they interact with us in ways that we
don't know like this example you and
what was that that was B I don't know I
don't know but I mean I think there's a
reason the matrix resonated with
everybody so hard they were like okay
yes something going on about that yeah
yeah and that's of one of the reasons
why I think the not only matrix
resonated but also a lot of the the
techniques in technology that were
indicated and and leveraged and used
within that that movie are now like oh
we're about to go through that yeah so
we'd better get our [ __ ] together
ya know my dude oh my gosh I mean I you
know I love it John this is this has
been super duper fun well thank you for
me too
me too I really appreciate the
invitation to join you here good John I
really appreciate you thank you so much
for coming out of the show your wellness
was a blast we'll have some of your
links in the bio ok - and exactly
speaking success Lincoln - bye Oh check
it out thank you again
you're wel huge thank you yes and thanks
everyone for tuning in if you guys had a
good time definitely give us a subscribe
give us a comment below with your
thoughts share the video with other
people get talking about the things that
we talked about that's really important
actually the leadership at the buffet
vs. leadership on empty dance floor and
definitely go and create with the
content don't just watch but go and make
something with it write about it make a
video about it
I'm gonna talk to other people about it
maybe start a business with it you know
how to do go do that and thanks for
tuning in everyone if you guys want us
to keep doing cool on sites like we're
doing right now at witty join us on
patreon
to continue supporting the studio
continue supporting the endeavor going
and highlighting more brilliant people
around the world so join us there thank
you very much much love peace
you